be organized and get prepared in
restaurant kitchens we call this mison
place
getting vegetables chopped stocks made
and sauce is ready
it's the religion by which all good
chefs live
i don't want to spend christmas in the
kitchen ignoring my family and friends
when we're all finally together
so i'm prepared with dishes that i can
cook in advance that will last over
christmas
adding a glazed ham to your holiday menu
is a great way to get ahead
it's delicious versatile and the
ultimate dish to have in the fridge
for any hungry guests who drop by
christmas would not be the same without
a beautiful delicious honey glazed ham
across that long christmas period this
can get you out of jail
quite easily ham salads ham sandwiches
ham egg and chips
this is a gammon what we could do now is
cook it so it becomes a ham
into a pan first things first
the water
cover it completely so the whole gammon
cooks evenly
the important part now is adding flavor
in there
carrots in the leeks
the more veg in there now the more
fragrant the broth becomes
once the ham is cooked that stock is
extraordinary
the base to a fantastic soup onion not
finely chopped
and in homemade ham stock
is packed with flavor so it's great for
making soups sauces
stews and risottos plus it can be frozen
so it's there when you need it
pan down
[Music]
peppercorns lightly crush then to give
it a christmas flavor i'm adding crushed
coriander seeds
two cinnamon sticks and four aromatic
bay leaves
up to the boil and then turn it down let
it simmer
and then skim it cooking a ham
isn't hard but it does take time this
two kilo joint takes two and a half
hours to simmer
before it's glazed and baked however it
is worth it
because it tastes absolutely delicious
so the glaze very very simple
demerara sugar madeira
that sweetens the glaze basically a
fortified wine
a couple of tablespoons in
and then shave vinegar
again couple tablespoons honey in
nice bring that out to the boil the
longer you leave it on the stove the
darker it becomes
you want your ham really nice and dark
then cook out the glaze for 3-4 minutes
that i'm happy with
[Music]
lovely
[Music]
right the gammon's cooked now onto the
plate
carefully snip the string
nice and gently peel back get rid of the
skin
then criss-cross it don't push too deep
let the knife do the work
stud it with some clothes
look at it almost looks like an albino
pineapple the glaze
and just carefully cover
start in the middle and let it work
round oh
god gently gently gently gently
it's not even roasted yet and it looks
amazing
beautiful look at that half the glaze
over now into the oven 15 minutes
[Music]
it started to colour get the rest of the
glaze
and pour that over look at it wow
the more effort passion
and love you show the ham now the
results are tenfold
look at it every five minutes out of the
oven
and glaze again back into the oven now
at 190 degrees we're gonna baste
and roast for 35 minutes
delicious next i'm going to make a pear
and saffron chutney
this is a fruity relish that works
brilliantly with a sweet aromatic ham
first things first slice the onion
fry the chopped onion in olive oil
without coloring it the important part
about this
stage is the fact that we're gonna layer
the chutney with textures
from onion to apple to pear
and a nice little block of ginger
grating the ginger so the ginger sort of
disappears
with the onions then add the spices
a good grating of nutmeg followed by a
teaspoon of cinnamon
and a teaspoon of cayenne pepper to give
it a kick delicious
i recently spent a lot of time in india
where chutneys originated
and discovered that whereas british
style chutneys tend to be cooked and are
usually quite sweet
indian ones are normally fresh spicier
and quite sour
next tamara sugar
[Music]
once that sugar's dissolved the white
wine vinegar all in
that's going to give us really nice sort
of sweet and sour flavor
from there our fruit
these are williams pears pear
is the star of the chutney so keep it
quite rustic
next add chopped cooking apples their
tartness gives a lovely contrast of the
sweetness of the pears
to give it great texture a handful of
sultanas
pinch of saffron this gives it a really
nice depth a rich
golden color saffron is the world's most
expensive spice
it's made from the dried stigmas of the
saffron crocus flower and as a general
rule of thumb
the deeper the colour of the threads the
better the quality
and to make it lighter the zest and
juice of two oranges
the orange and the saffron go
brilliantly well together
just squeeze that in there this chutney
is
brilliant with ham fantastic in salads
but equally as delicious
with fish whether it's a roasted cod a
grilled fillet of mackerel it goes
brilliantly well
bring that up to the ball cook that out
for 15 minutes
now tomatoes going at the end and that
brings a certain amount of freshness
to the chutney really helps to give it
that nice texture
[Music]
mix that in and literally cook it out
for 30 seconds
[Music]
what's great about this chutney is that
as it matures its flavor gets better
and better and it will keep for up to
six months
fill up the jar and that
is going to deliver amazing flavor
across christmas
and look my goodness me
that is fit for a king
[Music]
another chef's secret for the ultimate
christmas is keep your menu balanced
in the restaurant we work incredibly
hard to get the perfect balance of
flavors
textures and richness in every meal and
the same is true for getting it right at
home
so over christmas when you indulge in a
lot of rich food
it's crucial you have some light dishes
up your sleeve to really balance it out
sellers are the perfect antidote to
overextended bellies at christmas
but they don't have to be virtuous
affairs you can save that one for your
new year's resolution
i'm going to show you my secret
returning salad nicoise into a dish
dramatic and delicious enough
to merit a place in any christmas
celebration
sam's a real big hit in our household
over christmas it's delicious so
versatile
and tastes absolutely amazing now we're
going to do a delicious
salmon nicoise which is a really nice
way of reinvigorating your taste buds
across christmas first of all we're
going to poach this in a really nice
fragrant
court bouillon caught bouillon is just a
fancy name for poaching liquor
first add fennel with its lovely aniseed
flavour to water
then put in chopped celery onions and
salt
next pour in some white wine to give it
some body
add a splash of tarragon vinegar to give
it bite that wakes up everything that
really
makes it sort of slightly acidic but
more importantly it goes brilliantly
well with the salmon
to add flavor pop in a couple of star
anise and crushed white peppercorns
for freshness and zing put in a handful
of parsley a couple of bay leaves
and a sliced lemon
then bring the liquid up to the boil and
slip in the salmon
no need to season it because the water
called boulogne is all seasoned
beautifully
slip that in nice and gently skin side
down salmon's sweet delicate
and incredibly flavoursome now it's
going to go even higher in terms of
flavor
simmer the salmon for four to five
minutes then turn it off
and let it cool down in the liquid
salmon poached the next job is making
the light tarragon mayonnaise
tarragon mayonnaise with the difference
first of all
hand make it to start off with one egg
yolk
a little bit of heat in there teaspoon
of mustard
a little splash of tarragon vinegar in
whisk that first
nice big balloon whisk
and then when the bowl starts moving get
your cloth
open it up just go round
and keep that on there that's not going
anywhere now
yeah what we've got to do first
is whisk nice and thick so we can take
the oil
whisk with one hand sunflower oil in the
other
thumb over the end of the bottle
tip it upside down slowly drip it
feed the oil in whisk whisk whisk
drip drip drip and stop whisk and change
hands that way nothing's getting tired
whisk whisk whisk drizzle the sunflower
all in
stop once you've got that nice base you
can add the oil
quicker it's so easy
delicious when it's reached a luscious
thick consistency
add a squeeze of lemon juice and that's
your basic mayonnaise done
but i'm going to thin it down with water
because i want it much much
lighter almost like a vinaigrette which
is perfect for the salmon nicoise
it's all nice and creamy now add chopped
tarragon
the aniseed taste works really well with
the eggs and lemon zest
to liven it up and now the seasoning
always at the end salt pepper
i just mix that round look beautiful
it's got the texture of a custard almost
like a lemon curd
it's incredibly rich and it just falls
off the spoon
it's traditional to use boiled eggs in
salad nicoise but i'm going to do mine
differently
i'm going to cuddle the eggs first put
some water onto heat
then coat espresso cups or similar oven
proof containers with butter
next season each cup with pepper and
lime with a couple of basil leaves which
gives the eggs a lovely herby note
[Music]
we're going to season it with a classic
nicoise garnish
anchovies just roll that round
like a little ring and sit that at the
bottom of the basil
then crack in your eggs every little
component going on that plate
makes a big difference taking it up to
that little
extra special level place the espresso
cups in a bath of boiling water
and bake in the oven for about eight
minutes so the yolks are still soft and
creamy
with the eggs in the oven it's time to
bring the final components of the
nicoise together
to add color and freshness to the salad
marinade cherry tomatoes and olive oil
with shredded basil
and lemon zest the lemon goes
brilliantly with the salmon
the salmon's fragrant just take those
tomatoes
even further because this is a salad for
winter i want some of my ingredients to
be hot
after parboiling potatoes and green
beans i soated them together
you just give them a little toss
[Music]
what do you think of salad nicolas you
think of a beautiful summer salad
the exciting way of doing it now at
christmas is having a really nice hot
meal
when all the ingredients are prepared
it's time to bring the dish together
and dress the serving plate the secret
dressing
is starting from the center and working
your way out first of all
crispy salad leaves just in the center
of your plate what we're doing now is
building a base
i don't want a flat salad i want a salad
with energy excitement
and more importantly i want something
that looks
visually stunning slice the baby gem
lettuce hearts into wedges
and lightly roll them in the tarragon
mayonnaise and this is really important
because in 10 minutes time this salad
will still stay nice and crisp
buoyant exciting and more importantly
packed full of flavor next i sauteed
potatoes
around the outside i want the color now
i want the visual of impact
then i'm going to sort of interlink
the green beans next add the marinated
smarters
and some black olives
now for the exciting part removing the
eggs
from the espresso cup that little basil
leaf
is the crucial secret because that's
like a little blanket that slides it out
fingers crossed out
bang and i want that yolk
still nice and creamy inside the
saltiness
from the anchovy it's almost pureed at
the bottom of that egg
and that nice fragrant sweet basil
almost like they've been rolled in
perfume
delicious and finally the salmon and
just peel off
that skin wow the silver slipper
carefully flake the salmon and then
drape it on the salad
fillet amazing salmon
over you see the pinkness
incredibly aromatic and more importantly
every sliver of that salmon
it tastes amazing and that is a perfect
salmon nicoise for christmas
[Music]
so
you